foreign
by telling you about an email that I saw
in my inbox recently
now I have a pretty unusual inbox
because I'm a therapist and I write an
advice column called dear therapist so
you can imagine right what's in there
I mean I've read thousands of very
personal letters from strangers all over
the world
and these letters range from heartbreak
and loss Just Bats with parents or
siblings I keep them in a folder on my
laptop and I've named it the problems of
living
so I get this email I get lots of emails
just like this and I want to bring you
into my world for a second and read you
one of these letters
and here's how it goes
dear therapist
I've been married for 10 years and
things were good until a couple of years
ago
that's when my husband stopped wanting
to have sex as much and now we barely
have sex at all I'm sure you guys were
not expecting this
well last night I discovered that for
the past few months he's been secretly
having long late night phone calls with
a woman at his office
I Googled her and she's gorgeous I can't
believe this is happening my father had
an affair with a co-worker when I was
young and it broke our family apart
needless to say I'm devastated if I stay
in this marriage I'll never be able to
trust my husband again but I don't want
to put our kids through a divorce a
stepmom situation Etc what should I do
well
what do you think she should do
if you got this letter you might be
thinking about how painful infidelity is
or maybe about how especially painful it
is here because of her experience
growing up with her father
and like me you'd probably have some
empathy for this woman and you might
even have some how should I put this
nicely let's just call them not so
positive feelings for her husband
now those are the kinds of things that
go through my mind too when I'm reading
these letters in my inbox but I have to
be really careful when I respond to
these letters because I know that every
letter I get is actually just a story
written by a specific author and that
another version of this story also
exists it always does
and I know this because if I've learned
anything as a therapist it's that we are
all unreliable narrators of our own
lives
I am
you are
and so is everyone you know which I
probably shouldn't have told you because
now you're not going to believe my TED
Talk
look I don't mean that we purposely
mislead most of what people tell me is
absolutely true just from their current
points of view
depending on what they emphasize or
minimize what they leave in what they
leave out what they see and what they
want me to see they tell their stories
in a particular way
the psychologist Jerome Bruner described
this beautifully he said to tell a story
is inescapably to take a moral stance
all of us walk around with stories about
our Lives why choices were made why
things went wrong why we treated someone
a certain way because obviously they
deserved it why someone treated us a
certain way even though obviously we
didn't
stories are the way we make sense of Our
Lives
but what happens when the stories we
tell are misleading or incomplete or
just wrong
well instead of providing Clarity these
stories keep us stuck we assume that our
circumstances shape our stories
but what I found time and again in my
work is that the exact opposite happens
the way we narrate Our Lives shapes what
they become
that's the danger of our stories because
they can really mess us up but it's also
their power because what it means is
that if we can change our stories then
we can change our lives
and today I want to show you how
now I told you I'm a therapist and I
really am I'm not being an unreliable
narrator but if I'm let's say on an
airplane and someone asks what I do
I usually say I'm an editor and I say
that partly because if I say I'm a
therapist I always get some awkward
response like oh a therapist are you
going to psychoanalyze me and I'm
thinking a no and B why would I do that
here if I said I was a gynecologist
would you ask if I were about to give
you a pelvic exam
but the main reason I say I'm an editor
is because it's true now it's the job of
all therapists to help people edit but
what's interesting about my specific
role is dear therapist is that when I
edit I'm not just editing for one person
I'm trying to teach a whole group of
readers how to edit using one letter
each week as the example so I'm thinking
about things like what material is
extraneous is the protagonist moving
forward or is the protagonist going in
circles are the supporting characters
important or are they a distraction do
the plot points reveal a theme
and what I've noticed is that most
people's stories tend to circle around
two key themes the first is freedom and
the second is change and when I edit
those are the themes that I start with
so let's take a look at Freedom for a
second our stories about Freedom go like
this
we believe in general that we have an
enormous amount of freedom
except when it comes to the problem at
hand in which case suddenly we feel like
we have none
many of our stories are about feeling
trapped right we feel imprisoned by our
families our jobs our relationships our
pasts sometimes we even imprison
ourselves with a narrative of
self-flagellation I know you guys all
know these stories the everyone's life
is better than mine's story courtesy of
social media the I'm an imposter story
The I'm unlovable story nothing will
ever work out for me story that when I
say hey Siri and she doesn't answer that
means she hates me story I see you see
I'm not the only one
the woman who wrote me that letter she
also feels trapped if she stays with her
husband she'll never trust him again but
if she leaves her children will suffer
now there's a cartoon that I think is a
perfect example of what's really going
on in these stories the cartoon shows a
prisoner shaking the bars desperately
trying to get out but on the right and
the left it's open no bars The Prisoner
isn't in jail
that's most of us we feel completely
trapped stuck in our emotional jail
cells but we don't walk around the bars
to freedom because we know there's a
catch
Freedom comes with responsibility and if
we take responsibility for our role in
the story
we might just have to change and that's
the other common theme that I see in our
stories change those stories sound like
this a person says I want to change but
what they really mean is I want another
character in the story to change
therapists describe this dilemma as if
the queen had balls she'd be the king
I mean
it makes no sense right
why wouldn't we want the protagonist
who's the hero of the story to change
well it might be because change even
really positive change involves a
surprising amount of loss loss of the
familiar even if the familiar is
unpleasant or utterly miserable at least
we know the characters and setting and
plot right down to the recurring
dialogue in this story you never do the
laundry I did it last time oh yeah when
there's something oddly comforting about
knowing exactly how the story is going
to go every single time
to write a new chapter is to venture
into the unknown it's to stare at a
blank page and as any writer will tell
you there is nothing more terrifying
than a blank page
but here's the thing
once we edit our story the next chapter
becomes much easier to write
we talk so much in our culture about
getting to know ourselves but part of
getting to know yourself is to unknow
yourself to let go of the one version of
the story you've been telling yourself
so that you can live your life and not
the story that you've been telling
yourself about your life
and that's how we walk around those bars
so I want to go back to the letter from
the woman about the affair she asked me
what she should do
now I have this word taped up in my
office
ultracrepidarianism the habit of giving
advice or opinions outside of one's
knowledge or competence it's a great
word right you can use it in all
different contexts I'm sure you guys
will be using it after this TED Talk
I use it because it reminds me that as a
therapist I can help people to sort out
what they want to do but I can't make
their life choices for them only you can
write your story and all you need are
some tools so what I want to do is I
want to edit This Woman's letter
together right here as a way to show how
we can all revise our stories
and I want to start by asking you to
think of a story that you're telling
yourself right now that might not be
serving you well it might be about a
circumstance you're experiencing it
might be about a person in your life it
might even be about yourself
and I want you to look at the supporting
characters who are the people who are
helping you to uphold the wrong version
of this story
for instance if the woman who wrote me
that letter told her friends what
happened they would probably offer her
what's called idiot compassion
now an idiot compassion we go along with
the story we say you're right that's so
unfair when a friend tells us that he
didn't get the promotion he wanted even
though we know that this has happened
several times before because he doesn't
really put in the effort and he probably
also steals office supplies
we say yeah you're right he's a jerk
when a friend tells us that her
boyfriend broke up with her even though
we know that there are certain ways she
tends to behave in relationships like
the incessant texting or the going
through his drawers that tend to lead to
this outcome
we see the problem it's like if a fight
breaks out in every bar you're going to
it might be you
in order to be good editors we need to
offer wise compassion not just to our
friends but to ourselves this is what's
called I think the technical term might
be delivering compassionate truth bombs
and these truth bombs are compassionate
because they help us to see what we've
left out of the story the truth is we
don't know if this woman's husband is
having an affair or why their sex life
changed two years ago or what those late
night phone calls are really about and
it might be that because of her history
she's writing a singular story of
betrayal but there's probably something
else that she's not willing to let me in
her letter or maybe even herself to see
it's like that guy who's taking a
Rorschach test you all know what
Rorschach tests are a psychologist shows
you some ink blots they look like that
and asks what do you see
so the guy looks at his ink blot and he
says well
I definitely don't see blood
and the examiner says all right tell me
what else you definitely don't see
in writing this is called point of view
what is the narrator not willing to see
so I want to read you one more letter
and it goes like this
dear therapist
I need help with my wife
lately everything I do irritates her
even small things like the noise I make
when I chew
at breakfast I noticed that she even
tries to secretly put extra milk in my
granola so it won't be as crunchy
I feel like she became critical of me
after my father died two years ago I was
very close with him and her father left
when she was young so she couldn't
relate to what I was going through
there's a friend at work whose father
died a few months ago and who
understands my grief I wish I could talk
to my wife like I talked to my friend
but I feel like she barely tolerates me
now
how can I get my wife back
okay
so what you probably picked up on is
that this is the same story I read you
earlier just told from another
narrator's point of view her story was
about a husband Who's Cheating his story
is about a wife who can't understand his
grief
but what's remarkable is that for all of
their differences what both of these
stories are about is a longing for
connection and if we can get out of the
first person narration and write the
story from another character's
perspective suddenly that other
character becomes much more sympathetic
and the plot opens up
that's the hardest step in the editing
process but it's also where change
begins
what would happen if you looked at your
story and wrote it from another person's
point of view
what would you see now from this wider
perspective
that's why when I see people who are
depressed I sometimes say you are not
the best person to talk to you about you
right now because depression distorts
our stories in a very particular way it
Narrows our perspectives the same is
true when we feel lonely or hurt or
rejected we create all kinds of stories
distorted through a very narrow lens
that we don't even know we're looking
through
and then we've effectively become our
own fake News broadcasters
I have a confession to make
I wrote the husband's version of the
letter I read you
you have no idea how much time I spent
debating between granola and pita chips
by the way I wrote it
based on all of the alternative
narratives that I've seen over the years
not just in my therapy practice but also
in my column when it's happened that two
people involved in the same situation
have written to me unbeknownst to the
other and I have two versions of the
same story sitting in my inbox
that really has happened
I don't know what the other version of
This Woman's letter is but I do know
this she has to write it because with a
courageous edit she'll write a much more
nuanced version of her letter that she
wrote to me even if her husband is
having an affair of any kind and maybe
he is
she doesn't need to know what the plot
is yet
because just by virtue of doing an edit
she'll have so many more possibilities
for what the plot can become
now sometimes it happens that I see
people who are really stuck and they're
really invested in their stuckness
we call them help rejecting complainers
I'm sure you know people like this
they're the people who when you try to
offer them a suggestion they reject it
with yeah no that'll never work because
yeah no that's impossible because I
can't do that yeah I really want more
friends but people are just so annoying
what they're really rejecting is an edit
to their story of misery and stuckness
and so with these people I usually take
a different approach and what I do is I
say something else I say to them
we're all gonna die
I'll bet you're really glad I'm not your
therapist right now
because they look back at me the way
you're looking back at me right now with
this look of utter confusion
but then I explained that there's a
story that gets written about all of us
eventually
it's called an obituary
and I say that instead of being the
authors of our own unhappiness
we get to shape these stories while
we're still alive
we get to be the hero and not the victim
in our stories we get to choose what
goes on the page that lives in our minds
and shapes our realities
I tell them that life is about deciding
which stories to listen to and which
ones need an edit and that it's worth
the effort to go through a revision
because there's nothing more important
to the quality of our lives and the
stories we tell ourselves about them
I say that when it comes to the stories
of Our Lives
we should be aiming for our own personal
Pulitzer Prize
now most of us aren't help rejecting
complainers or at least we don't believe
we are
but it's a role that is so easy to slip
into when we feel anxious or angry or
vulnerable
so the next time you're struggling with
something remember
we're all gonna die
and then pull out your editing tools
and ask yourself
what do I want my story to be
and then
go write your masterpiece
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]